well here's a lot of talk about you BB
ya BB ya near time says that like you
know I you know you you and I are
similar in many ways right very
different but similar that we both came
from mad that was your one of your first
jobs it's my first job MADtv me too and
but I feel like and you'd been in movies
I mean what movie we heard I watched a
movie that you were in that we were
amazing it was that the fight the
warrior yeah you were great in that
thank you right and I'd seen you in old
school remember you run that's movie
yeah but two movies hangovers when you
guys start talking
but what really put you on a different
level I think is your podcast mmm fight
on the kid right I mean that is making
you good money yeah and now you have a
neighbor coward here yeah we I don't
know I mean I shot the certainly shot
the spin-off you know it's funny because
because uh the the the it was a it's
been a good three years right where I've
been doing this TV and I've been did
podcast has become this monster and then
stand up and all that and I won number
one comic of all time and oh wow yeah
National Council of community experts
who was on that [ __ ] of council
Richard Pryor dead serious and they
contacted this Bureau Oh him Carlin dead
right yeah what's all yeah thought yeah
Caesar Caesar yeah red buttons but yeah
I know but but like I I kind of like
it's funny because I kind of gave up on
acting right I hate acting so much cuz
it hurt me so much I get it it broke my
heart so this business yeah so I gave up
I was like mmm I don't care and then
along comes this podcast and you know
it's kind of like all of a sudden all I
guess when you become well I guess when
things are successful like you're doing
lots of TV
you know you don't even realize it you
know when I gave up a bunch of [ __ ]
started happening I guess what I'm
saying I didn't expect to make money on
the podcast yeah I did expect this
podcast to be like that I wanted to just
do a podcast because it was the only way
I could sell tickets on the [ __ ] road
like cuz I get your podcast before you
did fighter that's the one that you did
buy yeah yeah that was like Sanford and
Son right I had six exactly yeah and I
got tired of going to the you know do
Townsend on Thursday and Friday and not
being able to sell tickets yeah I got
tired of having clubs have to pay for
the room so I was only doing it so I
could sell tickets right but you know I
just wanted to stand up to big crowds
that's all I wanted right and that's you
guys that you this.what yeah yeah yeah
but again when it happens it happens it
sneaks up on you we are like oh I still
don't believe it and I still keep
waiting for it to go away yeah for me
it's a similar in many ways where I feel
like this podcast has I too did a pilot
and I think that it's all a part of the
different choices that I've made like
I've been you know I don't remember this
but when Ken was getting a lot of like
parts and I wasn't working you gave me a
pep talk at The Comedy Store and you
said it's gonna work out you're so funny
you know I mean like you really like
because I was on the verge of little
memory I remember like I was gonna kill
myself well I saw you yeah I didn't like
what I saw
cuz you seemed very broken at that
moment I was broken like you just didn't
care and I and III don't like that kind
of apathy that worries me you know it
does because I always said to you I've
seen you if you can do what I've seen
you do in just 20 minutes
you can do anything right anything and I
think that you should look at and I
think especially for you I think you
should look at comedy as a process of
discovery in other words what the [ __ ]
is what the [ __ ] is left inside of you a
lot of greatness I think you could be
one the greatest comics period but and
I'm not talking about I hate when people
say this because I don't mean I don't
even like the idea of work hard I don't
like the idea focus I don't want those
words and I don't like the idea of I
don't even like saying to a grown man
you know you could be this and I think
that's ridiculous I do think that you
could put yourself in a mindset that
says I'm gonna wake up every morning and
just sit and see what shows up
what am I gonna discover so you know
Flannery O'Connor the great writer who
died of MS at 39 years old in the 30s
now she's an amazing writer and you
people would not literary say what but
but no no that she's a great writer and
and she she said I sit in my typewriter
every morning not to write but in case
something happens and it's an active
thing okay III tell he's I told the
story thousand times in 2001 when
there's a guy from [ __ ] a Russian guy
who won the Fields Medal in mathematics
and and that's like the Nobel Prize in
mathematics and he had figured out that
there was a theorem a mathematical
theorem that they didn't even know
existed they weren't sure if it was
actually a legitimate question but he
answered the question and prove that it
existed and the answer was I think three
hundred and fifty seven pages long okay
you [ __ ] so a handful of mathematicians
looked at it and went holy [ __ ] this guy
this has been floating around since the
1800s and and they said this guy is one
of the great mathematicians of all time
let's give him the million dollar prize
he rejected it why he disappeared
why because he said you know they found
him in a cabin living with his aunt in
Siberia a year later and he said why are
you giving me the award I am just a
receiver I happen to have a certain
genetic makeup maybe wiring in my brain
that was able to channel that theorem
the theorem has always existed in the
great template in the sky oh my god so
this is a very important way to look at
life you're right it's a very good
important way to look at life because he
just kept showing up he kept showing up
it's an act of faith so why don't you do
that with your stand up you son of a
because I don't like your [ __ ] tone
right now and let me say this right now
I've never been [ __ ] afraid of you
I'll paintbrush your face I understand
that and I know you think that you're
stronger either you could destroy me do
you might as well do it no stop stop sir
all right but let me say something don't
ever talk to me like that
and number two I can't put your fingers
don't point your fingers at me all right
how about one that's all right
I know exactly what you're [ __ ]
talking about yeah alright because I am
the laziest guy right ever to show up in
this town right that's I am a [ __ ]
receiver also friend that's okay and
I've received in the ass man you missed
my whole point you said seve dicks in my
ass
I know exactly I was talking right I'm
sorry I receive all the time
hold on there was something I had
another thought that was brilliant go
ahead sorry no I really got what you
said think here that was good no there's
something else
[ __ ] I'll forget it no I lost it oh man
alright keep going
just put yourself in a process of
discovery yeah how'd you meet
[Music]